good morning Hank it's Tuesday greetings
from an undisclosed location where
they're filming the Looking for Alaska
who was show it's question Tuesday they
did that I answer real questions from
real nerdfighters let's get right to it
what would you nominate is the most
overrated fruit for me it's definitely
of the Loom I just think massively
overrated any good book recommendations
I really enjoyed this biography of
rosalind Franklin which I would show you
but it's currently part of my very
complicated tripod setup it's not so
much a tripod as it is a sculpture but
anyway there's the biography of rosalind
Franklin how do you stay happy when so
much of the news we hear about is bad oh
I don't stay happy I get really angry
and discouraged but I don't want to be
like merely angry and discouraged
because I don't think that reflects the
whole human story like a lot of people
got married today and wonderful babies
were born god I love babies I mean not
enough to have another one but in the
abstract my point is that lots of people
made their like best ever memories today
human life is vast and it contains
multitudes and I don't want to essential
eyes it into one narrative or another
what is your Myers Brigg personality
type and does it happen to be INFP I
don't really believe in personality
tests but it is nonetheless very
impressive that you correctly guessed my
myers-briggs result what's the best
thing that happened to you in the last
week meeting all the actors and seeing
all the sets for the Looking for Alaska
show has been really amazing also
vulture named the Anthropocene reviewed
one of their favorite podcasts which was
cool but the best thing that happened to
me this week was that my kids and I
planted peas in the garden I'm very
excited for my peas what are you
planning in the garden this year
lots of stuff how did you quit smoking
with nicotine gum the hard part was
actually quitting the nicotine gum
what song makes you cry sometimes I cry
when I listen to the best-ever death
metal band out of Denton by the mountain
goats I keep finding spiders in my
bedroom and bathroom and my parents have
told me they have no sympathy for my
situation how do I get them to care
enough to help me get rid of these
spiders so I think the most likely
underlying issue here is that your
parents may be human shaped
conglomerations of spiders in which case
I mean of course they're not going to
kill their own kind so you just got to
live with your spider parents what's
your favorite word right now
hermeneutics I don't really know what it
means but that's never slowed me down if
you could have the super powers of any
of the Avengers for a day which would
you choose
is there an Avenger who has the power to
think about like approximately what the
response to an email should be and then
have a fully formed email
appear in the compose box because that
one who's your favorite Catholic saint
probably st. Francis although if sister
Corita Kent were to be canonized she
would immediately become my favorite
Catholic saint as explained in this
recent art assignment video are you ever
gonna write a new book I hope so
have you ever considered writing a
memoir I sort of am monthly in the form
of the anthropocene reviewed over under
or in-between through as Robert Frost
put it the only way out is through
alright Hank I have to go back to
watching things that I imagined 15 years
ago
become visible I will see you on Friday